hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to three weird games this
teeth-brushing simulator ah oh hi oh god
I don't know if that's how the human
face works I don't know if I can fold my
face at the nose level to look down Wow
oh I don't know if that's how that works
either that's the top of my head are you
kidding me what is that was a little in
no that's my nose that's my nose cuz
that's a nostril
wow that's pretty incredible okay is
this really all there is oh okay don't
ask why but I have a super clicker
mouse-click are enabled
whoa and I got turned up the volume for
this I'm not gonna do that again cuz
that was terrible I guess this is just
you know why is there something else to
this there's got to be something else to
this it can't be just this this is weird
by itself but it cannot be just this
what is that
you guys hear that there's something
happening in the background here it's
really subtle but you can definitely
hear it oh it's car noises now that
there's something else there to sign it
sounds like wind why would there be wind
in here
that's not wind hesitant to turn up the
volume because I think it's gonna jump
scare me or something
cam listening
but yeah I knew it I knew you were gonna
I knew it oh I freaking knew it I knew
it I knew you were gonna do that
alright I guess I keep whoa what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is happening
alright well gonna keep brushing gotta
make sure I get hundred and twenty
brushes per minute what I'm sure I've
I'm literally speechless
oh oh whoa whoa
oh well there we go again
oh what the [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] what
what what
okay um Wow yeah that was uh that was
really something yeah I paid money for
that one I don't know how I feel about
that whoo I think my life has changed I
feel like a different person
I feel I feel bad I feel like I might
vomit actually I think I think something
about that music just absolutely
destroyed my brain like everything about
my brain has reset I'm already
forgetting memories for my childhood
there just like slipping away from me so
I'm pretty sure that game will kill me
in seven days
okay cool moving on all right so this
game is from the maker of the say of the
this is the same creator as the guy who
made toothbrushing simulator there was
no English version
I think this is called Slav squat
simulator why is there so much motion
blur when you move on the on the
cigarette there's so much motion blur I
do believe that is the entire game I
don't think there's anything else e you
can do besides that that's that whole
game I paid 50 cents for that welcome to
the game we're working rescue princesses
from a tower you heard that right and
then you get to date them I think that's
what it says so it's a roguelike game
where there's princesses that are in a
tower and this is just a very early
prototype demo but the concept was so
cute I thought I had to play it so I'm a
knight with a wedgie and I got to go in
there and I got a wait a minute there I
go I'm off I'm adorable Oh God all right
cool
great why is there a dragon in the Xbox
should I play it on a controller is it
one of those things it's better for a
controller hello hi oh hello what my
what a big you have four arms a big nose
I'm sorry I'm sorry didn't mean to screw
up your desk you're the 442nd Thoth
that's comes here looking for the floor
surface stone do you think that because
I'm an NPC I should attend to you maybe
you want everyone to care about you go
on and find yourself another adventure
to live alright I'm not sorry about your
desk okay Wow roll all right interesting
there's an oh there's something here
wait what wait what the hell wait what
oh I tricked myself I thought it went
around a corner but it did not okay hey
bud how you doing nice face greetings
fellow Knight welcome to the Dragons
Kass
Mountains root lots of princesses in
countless dangers await you on the other
side of that door downstairs all of us
came looking for that so we're doing
some work out here to get prepared for
the challenge all right
cool great I've been lifting these rock
ledges good good talk this romantic dawn
doors but the one thing thumb my
manliness okay all right cool you guys
are great love you guys
what is this gold moondust oh we I'm a
little unsure as to what I'm supposed to
do but I'm gonna charge headlong into
the door here and see what happens
may I there's princesses too risky Oh
oops well that's easy enough
Hey Oh interesting almost got me there
all right what do we got here spat all
right I don't know if that's what oh hey
bud how you doing oh god you're an enemy
interesting so I think when this is
supposed to be developed it's gonna be
like procedurally generated it's gonna
be completely oh uh yeah all right all
right okay yeah I see I see I see I'm
gonna get you yeah get rekt and that's a
bad combat it's pretty good got tar and
something I don't know what I got uh
pardon oh I see interesting all right oh
I don't know if I wanted to do that okay
so there's wind here interesting okay
good Hey whoa you owe you a boss okay ha
well I'm the boss too I don't know what
I'm supposed to do about you oh wait how
do I am I supposed to be able to block
but I can dodge oh you're dead no you're
not all right cool
good it's uh it obviously needs polish
but that's the thing about an early demo
okay I've taken a lot of damage Oh what
is this oh I can't see the camera turn
so slow the camera turns so slow camera
definitely needs some next sensitivities
try that oh that's a little better
probably be all the way up for all I
care
don't kill me no don't ah what did I
just ask for you to do all right well
you suck oh it's still too slow it's
still too slow are easy enough okay oh
okay you're down whoa
I just squashed him into the dust okay
what does this do
Oh so I can get back oh that's
handy-dandy
okay so far so good that automatically
save when I walk over it or what where's
this gosh darn princess that's what I'm
really here for I heard there was dates
whoa what happened I'm sorry I and I got
turned around again you are not worthy
for this tutorial rescue princess and
come back that's what I want to do I
want to rescue a princess I don't know
where to get a princess where's princess
use princess princess princess we
suddenly the camera got a lot more
responsive I don't know when that
happened
princess Burns has retired franchise oh
I made a mistake okay
ah big jello cubes I don't like that ow
you suck oh you suck more than I thought
you would oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh
hell yeah oh okay I'm getting the hang
of this
poopee life potion did that just say
poopy life potion did I just lose is
that a poopy life potion
I got a poopy life potion I don't know
what that oh oh that was poopy it only
did one heart that's the Pooh pious life
potion I've ever seen you guys going to
kill the princess you better not they're
not who I am the best princess hey I've
come to rescue you hey how are you all
right cool um I thought you'd be alive
oh I thought you were a kobold but
you're wearing chainmail Heights oh damn
kobolds come on take me out of here oh
cool yeah and yeah you don't have a key
well you know ah just take this then Oh
key here we go full backpack oh there we
go that dragon is seriously gotten into
kidnapping princesses into the castle
all right cool you are a zombie I'm the
zombie princess of the undead Kingdom
thanks for freeing me honorable Knight
oh okay yeah okay cool um you're tall
you were very tall you want to go on a
little adventure with me you wanna not
saying little cuz I'm sure than you I'm
just saying do I have a hot dog on my -
my my my hot dog uh excuse me I do I
come from the honorable house dog first
name hot I how are you I am I'm good
you're even better by the looks of it
love the teeth I love seeing your love
being able to see inside you if you know
what I mean
anyway I'll get you on the flippety-flip
just gonna go oh you're following me
okay that's even better
that's even better hey let me just check
around here is that a keyblade that is a
keyblade that is hilarious that's really
funny
the funny the puns I like puns you like
puns lady I bet you like puns yeah I
mean I don't have puns at the ready I'm
not exactly a humorous type of person
but watch out hey watch out muscles get
a little active you know how it is when
you have this many muscles they just
come first out at any moment so strong
that your breasts you should be you
should be I'm very impressive what did
you get me by the way did you give me
meat I think did you okay well I got I'm
dying you know how you remember do you
say welcome to a tutorial use those
verbs you have in your inventory to
relist bye I just ate them I just did I
just did that I just mmm hey lady lady
listen sorry did you give me those ribs
okay all right well we're off to a good
start here we're off to a great start if
you know what I'm talking about hey
listen you've got an odor about you but
you know I'm getting used to it it's
like a Musk
let me give you some of this argh why
did you do this I thought we were
friends you told me to do that oh my god
hey lady did you do that did you make
the hands come out of the ground I ate
your ribs and things got weird anyway
I'll sketch follow me follow me lady
I'll get you to safety don't worry about
these things
swinging blades of doom don't worry
about me well me it we'll meet at the
other side all right cool hey just gotta
check this over here nothing yeah that's
what I suspected it was Boosh miss me ow
what's this one says you watching yeah
yeah pretty good right
oh how lady all right I'm not gonna
question it you are full of surprises
aren't you
well me too me too you know you wanna
know why my emblem is a hot dog well
it's exactly what you think it is wink
oh wow oh well didn't expect to be here
all right well hey hey how you doing
there Oh shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo
shoo shoo shoo ow that hurt a lot I was
at full health when I came in here how
did I lose it already all right take
some of this poop eNOS all right did I
win I think I oh hi big guy oh hey oh
you've got a mushroom brain that's
bizarre
okay all right Wow I don't think that's
supposed to happen what's happened is
this the far beyond the demos over
congrats you reach the end what what
wasn't I supposed to be some kind of
boss or do some mirror right enjoy your
victory reading the credits what what
princess princess oh you are
you're a slice of something special oh
my they're such a small team they must
be such hard-working people you know
what they are they are I knew I would
support their Kickstarter campaign and
read a nice press review if I could you
know this is so confusing to me I still
don't know what's going on oh do you
have worms in your side
Oh it'll get back into the adventure
soon all right you know this is pretty
picturesque right here just few of us
man okay and hermano I guess I don't get
to do that that was pretty good that was
pretty good I like that that was pretty
good it needs a lot of polish but
there's a core element here that I like
I didn't get to go on a date which was
really what I was hoping for but you
know it's it was pretty close so I guess
I got to give it to it all right cool I
guess I'm out of here this one is called
bird by example birds
good lord Bert's just mama just mama
birds birds many birds Wow birds
yikes Birds good lord Birds holy [ __ ]
Birds Maxima bird I'm gonna go for good
Lord Birds just because actually I'm
gonna go to 69 yeah experts you know
what I feel that the experts okay here
we go Birds I don't know what this game
really is oh hi our bodies are real now
we have needs this is important for the
game
ooh woz move left click violence rekt
click toggle cursor oh why would I need
to toggle the oh I can zoom out oh
that's good
alright Wow okay um what are you doing
right ok are you trying to do something
that you shouldn't be doing listen mama
ain't too happy about that
I think what are you doing what are you
guys doing ok so when I read about this
game it's supposedly oh my god you're so
loud it supposedly was about something
about like deep learning so these these
birds actually learn from me or
something like that
I don't know they learn based on what
I'm doing I guess
ok Oded so how many birds are dead what
are you doing oh my goodness
alright well your Oh Birds ok if I punch
this tree two more fruits come out hi
well you're just jumping and punching
ain't you 15 dead ok good
you know actually that's for the best
population is a little overgrown I'm
gonna go away from this I'm gonna try to
escape oh there's a great big world out
here hey family oh hi what the hell how
did you get up there how'd you guys get
over here and also why are you over here
oh you're leaving ok that one's just
gone
oh they squeak when they jump I squeak
when I jump I regret having this many
birds whee ok there I go I guess Oh
death oh okay oh I see I'm gonna reset
this just real quick
it's not gonna go well but oh okay so if
I jump how many are gonna start jumping
none of them oh my God look at me Asians
Christmas I'm gonna turn down the bird
level we're gonna go for just birds
let's restart this bad boy oh that's not
better okay bird let there be Birds
there they are I don't know what you
guys are doing but oh there's a cave
what there's a cave Wow okay okay oh
whoa whoa whoa uh I'm sorry what what's
down here why is there something down
here what sleep sleep
what no there's something guys friends
family there's something here there's
something beyond here you okay are you
all dead you're all dead I don't know
what's it there is more down there I saw
more there was more but why is there
more I don't understand the why of it
the why is what's eluding me that was a
lot of birds okay birds come with me
come with me Birds we have to go down
there uh okay that hurt well you're a
red one ain't you look at that bird look
at that bird look at that sweet bird
nice bird let's see if we can survive
this fall sleep mortal Birds
there's a secret to be discovered here
and I'm not sure I like it
camp oh I can punch that all right well
yes guys in the whole games running a
little slow whoa wait what wait what
what what what she will always be happy
who will always be happy what are you
talking about
wake up wake up no no wake up wake up
wake up there we go yeah wake up come on
cowboy there we go okay she will always
be happy there's a lot dying mama is
that you mama mama mama okay I don't
know how I got here but mama don't look
so good I think my legs are broken I'm
pretty sure my legs are broken
hi hello
okay yeah this is yeah my legs are very
broken uh didn't know that could happen
there is no mystery did I clip through
the floor or something when I was
there's nothing for you here ah right
okay I'm very confused boy Oh
alright men in black you're early ah uh
oh it's you ah um well I don't know who
are you ah this is the other side of
that door I was trying to bust open my
legs are broken I can't really move well
why are your guy's legs not broken mine
very broken hey where does that lead if
you will always be happy I know she'll
always be happy well what about me what
about my needs
will I ever be happy probably not oh
it's the same thing okay alright well
mama I don't think I was supposed to get
through it I I am clipping through
things I shouldn't be clipping through I
suspect I don't know why but this this
particular bird has noclip enabled
alright mama I'm gonna show you the
business oh wow that's that's awful
that's horrible this looks like a murder
scene anyway I think this is fitting I'm
gonna leave this right here thank you
everybody so much for watching three
weird games I don't know why this exists
but it does and I don't even know if I
got to the bottom of it but I feel like
I did so thank you everybody for
watching if you want to play these games
for yourself above them in the
description and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
you